nicki minaj has made her way to the real
housewives of potomac reunion i'm very
excited about that on thursday both
nikki and bravo host andy cohen shared
photos together on the set of the
reunion special the rapper wrote in the
caption guess who [ __ ] hashtag
anaconda
rhop coming soon on bravo tv
in andy's post he wrote it's the reunion
i could never get away with at the end
of hours tonight nicki minaj surprised
the real housewives of potomac and did
her own thing hashtag andy konda and
thanks to nikki's hairstylist we got a
peek at what happened behind the scenes
who won it who's that why
the super bass rapper's surprise
appearance comes after she jokingly said
she would be taking over reunion hosting
duties from andy back in july nikki
shared her take on a trailer for the
show where the cast talks about their
lives to the tune of her hit track
moment for life about the cars that you
buy
keeping the secrets of christ hold on
that believe it and potomac surprise and
you can't turn your back on the line
don't worry about me who's spilling out
the tea nicki's caption read i'll be
hosting the reunion let me know what
y'all want me to ask and andy was not
opposed to it in august the watch what
happens live host told et quote i would
love to figure out a way to work her
into the reunion and i would love to be
able to bring her out and see what she
has to say and wants to ask the women
adding the answer is i'm totally
receptive to figuring out how to work
her into what we're doing well it
clearly worked because nikki did just
that i do feel like a queen and it turns
out the housewives of potomac were all
for nikki's appearance too gisele bryant
told et last month she was working hard
to make it happen okay you know what's
so crazy i just text about
three powers that be in our world oh and
i got questions for nikki i just want a
kiki oh you you have questions for her
she can ask you whatever you want as
long as you can ask her back i get it
i feel like
you're like what a better kiki like
nikki is like fun funny she's shady like
she's like my kind girl as for candace
dillard bassett who put her singing
career in full force this year she told
et in august that she'd love to work
with nikki even after fans thought the
rapper shaded her song drive back
[Music]
what did you make of nicki minaj
throwing a little slight shade on the
song on instagram
okay so
the the nicki minaj
saga because it's like ever growing and
changing right like i was live tweeting
last week's episode and she's literally
live tweeting with us
and like asking for opinions and giving
her opinions
it's i'm gonna have no edges it's too
much it's just too much stress for me um
but i i did not take what she said about
my song as shade i took because the w
what happened was watch what happens
live
posted under her post about
hosting the reunion um that she should
do a um
a feature
remix yeah a remix of drive back and she
was like what's that like she didn't
know what they were talking about but
then after they explained oh we're
talking about candace's song she said oh
it's a nice song
and but then she's like oh but we have
things to talk about at the reunion and
now we're gonna head girl bye like get
on this track and then let's go home i
ain't talking to you about nothing to
happen in season five good night